scp 682 versus an industrial grade  blender followed by strong centrifuge  could this the most hardcore of  industrial kitchen equipment finally  take down the hard to destroy reptile a  682 tissue sample was reduced into a  fine slurry by the blender and then  placed into the centrifuge which slowly  increased to a truly insane number of  rotations per minute and the sample  exploded severely injuring 12 members of  personnel and almost killing dr carlson  one of the lead researchers on the  project it turned out that scp-682's  flesh contains antimatter hence the  violent chemical reaction that  transpired naturally further testing of  this matter was forbidden by the o5  council to reduce the number of  unnecessary explosions occurring on the  site i guess we'll never truly know the  outcome on this one huh